invité de notre journal marcel boussac
joue sa dernière carte en proposant
d'apporter ses biens pour sauver ses
usines
raymond barre avant geass un regard
attentif sur le panier de la ménagère
l'entourage des détenus plus surveillés
un visiteur de prison inculpé mais
laissé en liberté
là messieurs bonsoir la fin d'un empire
la lente agonie du groupe boussac et
tout à la fois angoissant si l'on se
place aux côtés des travailleurs
ils craignent pour leur emploi et pour
la survie de leur usine et émouvante si
l'on regarde la situation avec les yeux
de marcel boussac 89 ans qui voit sa
fortune sa vie et son oeuvre partir en
miettes
marcel boussac qui a aujourd'hui décidé
de jouer son va tout pour sauver
l'emploi de ces onze mille salariés dans
un document qu'il a adressée au tribunal
de commerce de paris
il a accepté de renoncer la quasi
totalité de ses biens personnels pour
permettre le renflouement du groupe
mais les banques semblent vouloir
refuser l'aménagement financiers qu'ils
proposent ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que ce qu'on appelle l' empire
boussac n'est pas un tout homogène
d'un côté le cidf le comptoir textile
vingt-et-une société en règlement
judiciaire depuis le 30 mai nous l'autre
la fortune personnelle boussac
immobilier chevaux haute couture
journaux et cetera
marcel boussac est encore à ce jour
personnellement propriétaire est donc
responsable des affaires il a déjà
beaucoup vendu il fallait tôt ou tard se
résoudre à vendre encore ici pour
rembourser la ce matin marcel boussac
ces réseaux qui rachètera dior couture
peut-être quartier qui s'est mis sur les
rangs peut-être moët hennessy qui a déjà
racheté les parts fois en dior qui
rachètera l'aurore et paris turf
on ne sait pas encore quand aux 85
hectares des haras de jardy
ils font l'objet de diverses convoitises
immobilière d'ailleurs contrarié par un
projet d'achat par l'état en outre sur
beaucoup de ses biens personnels de
marcel boussac et spécialement sur les
haras il existe déjà des hypothèques
détenus par les banques pour garantir
d'autres dettes alors vendre les chevaux
c'est possible mais ce dernier sacrifice
de l'empereur du coton devra d'abord
être agréé par les banquiers le dossier
social c'est encore deux autres conflits
d'abord chez moulinex le mouvement de
grève avec occupation du sinn déclenché
à lens on s'est étendu ce matin la
plupart des entreprises du groupe
six en tout sont paralysées par la grève
et puis chez renault la situation reste
très tendue dans l'usiné de flins après
la décision prise ce matin toujours par
la cour d'appel de versailles décision
qui permet
à tout moment l'évacuation des grévistes
fin ou la direction je vous le rappelle
a décidé le chômage technique de 9000
salariés gens ne le sait n'a vécu les
premières heures de ce blocage
à l'heure actuelle les grévistes
occupent toujours l'atelier des grandes
presse depuis 14h 9000 des vingt mille
salariés de flins sont en chômage
technique pour une durée indéterminée
ils attendent tout comme les syndicats
la reprise des négociations
mais la direction de la régie ne semble
pas disposé à faire machine arrière
malgré les injonctions du médiateur
nommé par le tribunal de versailles
pendant ce temps la grève bouchons des
os est en train de paralyser totalement
lusine cgt et cfdt occupe le terrain le
problème de fond n'est pas de résoudre
le conflit qui est une question
importante mais c'est surtout de
résoudre les causes de ce conflit c'est
à dire de les négociations sur les
revendications et si les négociations
qui avaient satisfaction aux
revendications des lieux et bien le
travail pourrait reprendre dès demain
matin
et sinon et bien sinon c'est la
direction qui prend la responsabilité du
blocage de la situation et c'est grave
parce qu'il s'agit de l'intérêt d'une
autre usine nationale et c'est l'intérêt
national qui est en jeu d'autre part il
ya le problème de la sortie de la r18
est ce que la direction elle veut
saboter la régie s'ajoute ce soir aux
revendications des grévistes de flins
celle des neuf mille chômeurs techniques
qui entendent qu'on leur paye les
journées perdues
la hausse du prix de l'essence c'est
pour bientôt de toute façon avant le 1er
juillet je vous rappelle que le litre
d'ordinaire passera deux francs 48 et
celui de super à 2 francs 60 8 essais de
prix que raymond barre a beaucoup parlé
ce matin il l'a fait sur le terrain à
rungis en visitant pendant près de deux
heures le fameux marché d'intérêt
national avec des arrêts prolongés
devant les fruits et légumes des
volailles et les produits laitiers
un reportage de jean fau de l'indic
une atmosphère plutôt détendue et des
prix stables c'était l'ambiance ce matin
à rungis pour la visite de monsieur bart
pendant deux heures le premier ministre
a parcouru le plus grand marché
d'intérêt national de france un monstre
de 220 hectares où se rencontre tous les
jours 2000 vendeurs et 25000 acheteurs
et qui réalise un chiffre d'affaires
annuel de 16 milliards de francs
mais aujourd'hui monsieur bart a pu
constater que la réforme de rungis
entreprises il y a quatre mois
commençait à porter ses fruits
à commencer par la remise en marche des
téléviseurs qui assure la transparence
du marché
en diffusant les tendances des cours
dans tous les pavillons quant aux
professionnels de rungis il n'avait pas
oublié leurs doléances
l'application des marges bénéficiaires
instauré par vos services
on ne peut pas nous permettre de
travailler convenablement j'espère
monsieur le premier ministre vous
voudrez bien examinées de même des
données de notre problème je vous en
remercie
et vous prie de m'excuser de gérer toute
intervention sur la question des marges
regarderai la faire
une sorte que cela puisse être un
instrument normal de connaissances est
pas un instrument de contraintes va
supporter à la voir merci merci
régis connu pour ses accès de fièvre et
pas seulement sur les prix a donc
finalement réservé un accueil courtois
au premier ministre et si on n'a pas
offert de fleurs à monsieur bart on lui
a quand même offert des cerises sur cinq
francs le kilo pris deux groupes valéry
giscard d'estaing lui aussi est et en
banlieue parisienne aujourd'hui
inaugurait la nouvelle école nationale
du service du trésor marne la vallée
c'est le chef de l'état qui lorsqu'il
était ministre des finances avait lancé
en 73 le projet de cette école du trésor
monsieur giscard d'estaing exprimé le
souhait que cette école illustre dans
cette ville nouvelle
l'alliance du beau et de les contacter
valéry giscard d'estaing qui se rendra
vendredi à hambourg vendredi de cette
semaine pour y rencontrer l'occasion
d'un dîner privé le chancelier schmidt
notre vue qui doit préparer le conseil
européen de brême début juillet et le
sommet des pays industrialisés dix jours
plus tard mais il ne s'agit pas pour
autant d'un sommet franco allemand
le prochain aura lieu en septembre enfin
toujours à l'elysée une audience
remarquer aujourd'hui celle du radical
de gauche maurice faure mais ce n'est
pas à ce titre qu'il a été reçu par le
chef de l'état fait par exemple son
intérêt pour l'europe et du rôle qu'il
avait joué il ya 20 ans dans la
négociation du traité de rome
le présent à public lui a demandé ce
qu'il pensait d'un éventuel
élargissement de la communauté à la
grèce et l'espagne qui ont fait acte de
candidature
je fais partie d'une formation dans
laquelle on n'a pas besoin de demander
d'autorisation préalable au demeurant
jeu steam que la nature des rapports
entre la majorité et l'opposition est en
france beaucoup trop tendu y compris sur
le plan humain et cela j'estime front
depuis 20 ans par conséquent je trouve
tout à fait normal tout à fait naturel
plutôt d'avoir contribué
à vendre ses rapports plus normaux même
très modestement une petite phrase de
jacques chirac ce matin sur rtl le rpr
est actuellement en réserve
bien que faisant partie de la majorité a
précisé le maire de paris notre
mouvement n'a pratiquement plus aucune
responsabilité dans l'exercice du
pouvoir
nous sommes donc en réserve fin du
comité central du parti communiste à
huit clos claude poperen dans un rapport
estime que les communistes doivent faire
preuve d'imagination et d'esprit
d'initiative pour mener la lutte contre
la politique économique et sociale du
gouvernement
il juge par ailleurs tout à fait
minoritaire la contestation de certains
membres du parti
enfin aujourd'hui premier examen par les
sénateurs des grandes lignes du projet
de loi que le gouvernement déposera à
l'automne sur la réforme du statut des
collectivités locales c'est en quelque
sorte le grand conseil des communes de
france qui se penche sur son miroir
alors daniel brême comment est-ce que
tout cela a été accepté qu'elle était le
climat aujourd'hui au sénat on peut
ranger les 29 orateur en trois
catégories les impatients les méfiants
et les sceptiques les impatients à leur
tête le président du sénat lui-même
monsieur power ce dossier a été ouvert
il y à 40 ans je souhaite qu'il puisse
rapidement aboutir les méfiants tel
monsieur champex le socialiste où
monsieur au gué communistes soupçonnent
le gouvernement de vouloir gagner du
temps en ne déposant la loi-cadre que
dans six mois pour eux un slogan donnez
nous des sous il n'y a de vraies
réformes que celle là enfin les
sceptiques du style de monsieur de
tinguy du poët ils disent au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur bonnet réforme et
dont l'état avant de vouloir réformer
les communes quand on pense qu'il faut
vingt signatures et vingt contrôles pour
implanter un poteau électrique
alors votre réforme vous pensé ce n'est
pas pour demain lorsque les propos de
christian bonnet ont trouvé grâce quand
même auprès des sénateurs
curieusement plus dans les couloirs
conscience et par exemple sénateurs
monsieur bourgoin de lille hier qu'on
trouve dans les aspects positifs
l'attribution par les maires des permis
de construire
la possibilité pour les communes de
décider les équipements de la commune à
l'intérieur d'une subvention globale
sans remonter au ministère de tutelle
des salaires et des crédits d'heures
pour les mères la possibilité de
recruter du personnel de haut niveau
pour tenir tête
à celui de l'état et surtout surtout pas
de regroupement autoritaire b comme une
bête noire de tous les maires de petites
communes
il ya donc le projet de loi-cadre à
l'automne au parlement avant de passer à
un autre dossier je vous rappelle de
françois mitterrand ce sera notre invité
dans quelques minutes et que raymond
barre répondre à jean pierre elkabbach
et alain duhamel dans un carte sur table
en direct de bayonne après demain jeudi
la politique étrangère en quelques
télégrammes modération d'anouar el
sadate dans son jugement sur le plan
israélien propos de l'avenir de la
cisjordanie le président égyptien reste
déterminé à reprendre le dialogue avec
israël bien qu'ils jugent la réponse
israélienne à washington
floués non positive alors al sadate qui
a par ailleurs des ennuis avec son
ambassadeur à lisbonne l'ancien chef
d'état major de l'armée le général fazli
il avait attaqué très violemment le
régime de son pays le qualifiant d'
autocratique
il a aussitôt été suspendu de ses
fonctions et puis italie 5 124 jours
enchaîné à un lit sans pouvoir ni parler
ni guerre ni écouter la radio dans une
pièce de deux mètres sur deux c'est le
cauchemar que vient de vivre un
producteur de cinéma italien enlevé à
milan il ya un an et demi et que ses
ravisseurs viennent seulement de libérer
en sicile contre une énorme avance un
visiteur de prison
inculpé à paris depuis la ferme et
screen un contrôle de plus en plus
sévères et exercer vis-à-vis des deux
seules professions qui reste encore en
contact avec les prisonniers
les avocats d'abord et ce fut là faire
de maître thouanel tournoi incarcéré
quatre jours la semaine dernière pour
sortir régulière de courrier et puis les
visiteurs de prison
et là c'est donc à faire cordier jean
marie cordier 64 ans inculpé de remise
irrégulière de correspondance et qu'il
fait me libère jean cordier était l'un
de ses 15 cents visiteurs de prison les
visiteurs de prison à porto détenus
qu'ils visitent un réconfort moral mais
aussi la possibilité de préparer avec
eux leur réinsertion et leur hébergement
à leur sortie de prison
constamment surveillés ils n'ont en
aucun cas le droit de transmettre aux
détenus correspondance paquet ou quoi
que ce soit venant de l'extérieur
jean cordier ingénieur en retraite de
l'edf était depuis dix ans un visiteur
de prison
irréprochable
dix ans dix ans dans service à beaucoup
de détenus je pense que nous tenir
compte d'une erreur qui peut arriver à
tout le monde et qui provient d'un élan
du coeur et qu'on a mis assez grave
mais si je veux être l'interprète de
monsieur jean cordier
je dois dire qu'il a avant tout le souci
de la justice qu'ils considèrent qu'il a
eu tort et qu'il est normal que la
justice suive son cours
mais depuis l'évasion de mesquines on a
l'impression que les règlements dictée
par l'administration pénitentiaire
semble se durcir
il semblerait que la sécurité l'on porte
sur la réinsertion puisque d'une façon
étrange on confie les deux la même
administration et là où la méfiance est
de rigueur quand il s'agit de la
sanction et de la sécurité il faut de la
confiance et de l'amitié qu'il s'agit de
la réinsertion c'est pour ça que s'est
réduit au mois de janvier dernier notre
journal diffusé le portrait d'une
visiteuse de prison geneviève née terre
nous avions alors pu filmer à
l'intérieur de la prison de besançon et
recueillir des témoignages de détenus
sur leurs visiteurs
il ya quand même une union qui se fait
entre le visiteur de prison est le
détenu c'est une amitié qui s'établit ou
au fil des semaines
à part le fait quand on arrive dans le
système qui est répressif tels que la
justice il est bon des fois de
rencontrer des gens qui qui sont
désintéressés et qui ne cherchent pas à
enfoncer un peu plus dans le malheur
parce qu'en fait quand on est en prison
un malheureux une quarantaine d'appeler
aux arrêts pour avoir signé une pétition
à dijon une pétition qui réclamé la
gratuité des transports et des
permissions régulière voilà ce qu'on
apprend de source syndicale et qui
confirme une petite poussée de fièvre à
nouveau chez certains appelés cinq ans
après la sphère des comités de soldats
manifestation d'élus socialistes
aujourd'hui devant l'hôtel matignon pour
protester contre la politique de
l'emploi du gouvernement et cela nous
amène donc à notre invité françois
mitterrand et si vous ne voulez bien
françois mitterrand nous allons donc
reprendre le cours de l'actualité telle
que nous l'avons développée dans ce
journal
avec d'abord donc le dossier social et
cette première question que je voudrais
vous poser est ce qu'il faut
subventionner ce qu'on appelle les
canards boiteux est ce que le ps au
pouvoir aurait indéfiniment distribuer
de l'argent à des entreprises en
difficulté je pense à boue sable je
pense à manille france ne tenons pas
compte des deux exemples que vous venez
de citer
disons d'une façon générale c'était
votre question faut-il que l'état se
substitue aux entreprises privées
il faut dire que il s'est substitué
pendant ces vingt dernières années dans
des conditions qui n'étaient pas
acceptables
l'argent public c'est à dire l'argent
des contribuables a été accordée à la
sidérurgie à l'automobile et dans bien
d'autres domaines sans garantie réelle
cet argent généralement n'a pas été
remboursé et comme c'était de l'argent à
fonds perdus sans que pour autant l'état
est obligé les entreprises privées dans
ces secteurs si important à prévoir un
plan de restructuration à
d'investissement à se réorganiser pour
se tirer d'affaires ça a été si j'ose
dire un coup pour rien qui a été
finalement extrêmement coûteuse pour les
contribuables français bien entendu le
parti socialiste n'agirait pas ainsi par
exemple lorsque l'état si nous en avions
la charge
interviendrait dans une entreprise
privée pour tenter de la soutenir ce cas
peut se poser précisément pour le
textile ou bien pour manille france
alors ils prendraient des garanties il
exigerait un plan de sauvegarde
une contribution des capitaux privés et
il entrerait lui l'état c'est à dire la
puissance publique stern ou les français
par des participations financières
à l'intérieur de ces entreprises privées
voilà pourquoi je suis obligé de vous
répondre à la fois oui et non oui nous
soutiendrions les sociétés en péril
parce qu'il faut sauver l'emploi sauver
des industries nécessaires à la vie
nationale
le textile en fait partie comme hier il
était nécessaire de sauver l'ordinateur
mais nous n'aurions pas fait n'importe
quoi n'importe quand quand mitterrand
raymond barre tient le langage de la
vérité si du moins sa phrase favorite
est ce que la gauche au pouvoir pourrait
pourrait le tenir on vous reproche
souvent de tenir une un langage disons
plutôt vers la popularité bref une
certaine démagogie fieschi me reproche
au sort c'est ce qui se dit assez
facilement la rescue tdi le gouvernement
est un peu partial dans cette affaire
monsieur bart dis la vérité je ne mets
pas en doute l'idée qu'il s'en fait mais
quelle est la réalité aujourd'hui même
20 juin le parti socialiste a engagé
dans toute la france une campagne
nationale de protestation vous le savez
vous en avait parlé
on l'a vu quelques-uns de nos amis
maires des communes s'associent à cette
protestation sur le thème il ne vous
avais pas dit ça c'est à dire qu'avant
les élections législatives est parti de
la majorité qui était on le sait bien
en danger ont promis tout et n'importe
quoi sur quoi est ce que monsieur bart
est devenu premier ministre
on a peut-être oublié alors je vais
rappeler je vais lutter contre
l'inflation
je vais ramener la hausse des prix à un
niveau moins élevé je vais essayer de la
limite et en fin de compte à 6 et demie
d'augmentation pour cent par an dans un
premier temps on va essayer de sentir à
8% vers la première année il a échoué
un peu plus de neuf courses
en faisant payer cette baisse des prix
par eux environ par des centaines de
milliers de chômeurs de plus et il a pas
reconnu dire la vérité c'était d'alger
j'ai échoué jeudi j'ai pas arrivé et
aujourd'hui monsieur bart au lieu d'être
celui qui combat l'inflation est celui
qui préside un gouvernement qui va nous
mener à la fin de l'année à 11 à 12%
d'augmentation des prix dans l'année
battant les records et descend en
dessous battant les records de monsieur
chirac est entendu que pour l'instant
nous sommes dans une sorte de régime de
croisière de 14%
de la même façon sur le plan de la rue
structuration industrielle du pays il me
semble que monsieur bart n'a pas tenu
ses engagements
mais il est un point encore plus
sensible monsieur coupe est encore plus
sensible c'est que on avait dit aux
français que l'on essaierait de
maintenir leur pouvoir d'achat et vous
avez vu cette dégelée d'augmentation des
tarifs publics dès que les élections
sont passées les transports en
particulier les loyers hlm
on parle de l'essence sur tous les plans
parle pas des timbres tout ça qui n'est
pas négligeable
en vérité le gouvernement a attendu les
élections et a aussitôt procédé un
formidable boom des eaux et services
publics ne te sorte que par valeur
d'entraînement aujourd'hui c'est
l'ensemble de l'économie française qui
se trouve déportés comme ne leur ai pas
voulu monsieur bart mais comme il l'a
fait voilà pourquoi nous sommes
autorisés à répondre à monsieur bart ou
non de sa vérité que cette vérité très
incertaine et que s'il avait parlé
franchement aux français il est probable
que je n'aurais pas obtenu au mois de
mars les suffrages qui se sont amassés
sur les partis conservateurs si vite et
rendre le chômage augmente l'inflation
les thaïs public
le mécontentement sans doute aussi
grande réussite il est est ce que les
partis de gauche après leur défaite à
leurs divisions ne sont pas un peu hors
jeu dire que la moitié des français est
hors jeu non pas la moitié de reda mais
disons les états-majors jeu reality show
raid en raisins prudent la preuve c'est
que vous venez de corriger l'impression
qu'ils auraient pu donner ma réponse
pourquoi les états majors comment
peut-on séparer ce que vous appelez
les états majors de la masse des
français qui leur ont fait confiance on
a l'impression que ces populations sera
relayée par les syndicats par la base
ils sont à six points et les syndicats
route un très grand rôle à tenir le
parti socialiste pour ce qui le concerne
je parle en son nom est resté tout à
fait sol et sur son terrain et je dois
dire que le parti socialiste en dépit de
la déception qu'il a éprouvée devant
l'échec de la gauche entend que gauche a
pu constater cependant qu'il était la
seule formation politique à avoir eu des
gains au cours de ces dernières
élections 4% ce n'était pas suffisant
mais après tous les autres partis ont
perdu ses 4 % et si nous avons été en
effet éprouvé par le fait que nous
n'avons pas été mise en mesure
d'apporter aux travailleurs la politique
dont il avait besoin
ressentir désiré par la majorité des
français si les socialistes n'ont pu
obtenir ce résultat
il n'en reste pas moins engagé dans une
dynamique qui doit les conduire vers des
combats politiques futurs qui sont après
tout pas si lointain alors pourquoi
séparer les états majors jusqu'ici j'ai
le sentiment que le parti socialiste se
rencontrent un vaste courant populaire
sous mitterrand lors de sa dernière
conférence de presse de 14 balles et
richard destin à proposer un stand
d'initiatives qui réponde à certaines de
vos préoccupations
est-ce qu'on s'achemine vers un
consensus vers une cohabitation possible
pouvoir opposition cela aurait pu être
mieux engagé hier quand même cinq
initiatives nouvelles qui font grève
quand j'ai rencontré le président de la
république peu de temps après les
élections
j'ai nommé ray je ne reviendrai pas là
dessus sur ce nombre de propositions qui
me paraissait devoir non pas fournir un
statut de l'opposition ce qu'était une
notion très choquant mais établir de
meilleures relations de travail dans la
vie démocratique du pays entre
l'opposition et la majorité
monsieur giscard d'estaing a pris une
initiative que nous avons approuvé
quant à la présence
demande de l'opposition notamment
socialiste dans les délégations
internationales
j'avais également demandé que l'on put
mettre en oeuvre un projet de
rétablissement de la proportionnelle sur
ce long du procès dure à étudier les
j'aperçois que sur le plan municipal
monsieur giscard d'estaing semblent
aller dans ce sens demain aux prochaines
élections d'hier dans cinq en dire de
même un peu imprudent
il y aura des élections municipales pour
les communes de plus de 30000 habitants
à la proportionnelle et non plus sur la
base des listes bloquées que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui très bien on
parle aussi m'a-t-on dit d'un projet de
financement des partis politiques
proches au sein c'est ce qui se dit
assez facilement du mal à rester du
gouvernement est un peu partial dans
cette affaire monsieur bart dis la
vérité je ne mets pas en doute l'idée
qu'il s'en fait mais quelle est la
réalité aujourd'hui même 20 juin le
parti socialiste engagée dans toute la
france une campagne nationale de
protestation vous le savez vous en avez
parlé on a vu quelques uns de nos amis
maires des communes s'associent à cette
protestation sur le thème il ne vous
avais pas dit ça c'est à dire qu'avant
les élections législatives est parti de
la majorité qui était on le sait bien en
danger ont promis tout et n'importe quoi
sur quoi est ce que monsieur bart est
devenu premier ministre
on l'a peut être oublié alors je vais le
rappeler je vais lutter contre
l'inflation
je vais ramener la hausse des prix à un
niveau moins élevé je vais essayer de la
limite et en fin de compte 1,6 et demie
d'augmentation pour cent par an dans un
premier temps récit de sentir et 8 % la
première année il a échoué
un peu plus de 9% en faisant payer cette
baisse des prix par eux environ par des
centaines de milliers de chômeurs de
plus et l'a pas reconnu dire la vérité
c'était bien j'ai joué je n'y suis pas
arrivé et aujourd'hui monsieur bart au
lieu d'être celui qui combat l'inflation
est celui qui préside un gouvernement
qui va nous mener à la fin de l'année à
11 à 12% d'augmentation des prix dans
l'année
dans les reports et descendre en dessous
battant les records de monsieur chirac
est entendu que pour l'instant nous
sommes dans une sorte de régime de
croisière de 14%
de la même façon sur le plan de la rue
structuration industrielle du pays il me
semble que monsieur bah n'a pas tenu ses
engagements
mais il est un point encore plus
sensible monsieur copains encore
puissants si c'est que on avait dit aux
français que l'on essaierait de
maintenir leur pouvoir d'achat et vous
avez vu cette dégelée d'augmentation des
tarifs publics dès que les élections
sont passées les transports en
particulier les loyers hlm
on parle de l'essence sur tous les plans
par l'epad est un vrai tout ça qui n'est
pas négligeable
en vérité le gouvernement a attendu les
élections et aussitôt procédé un
formidable boom des eaux et services
publics ne sorte que à part valeur
d'entraînement aujourd'hui c'est
l'ensemble de l'économie française qui
se trouve déportés comme ne l'aurait pas
voulu monsieur bart mais comme il l'a
fait voilà pourquoi nous sommes
autorisés à répondre à monsieur bart au
nom de la vérité que cette vérité très
incertaine et que s'il avait parlé
franchement aux français il est probable
que il n'aurait pas obtenu au mois de
mars les suffrages qui se sont amassés
sur les partis conservateurs 6,8 et
rendent le chômage augmente l'inflation
les thaïs public
le mécontentement sans doute à une
grande réussite c'est laid est ce que
les partis de gauche après leur défaite
à leurs divisions ne sont pas un peu
hors jeu dire que la moitié des français
est hors jeu non pas la mousse et les
leurs et mais disons les états-majors
jeu reality sur et d'un raisin prudent
la preuve c'est que vous venez de
corriger l'impression que les plus
donner ma réponse
pourquoi les états majors comment
peut-on séparer ce que vous appelez les
états majors de la masse des français
qui leur ont fait confiance en l
impression que ces populations sera
relayée par les syndicats par la base
ils sont à 6 promus et les syndicats ont
un très grand rôle à tenir le parti
socialiste pour ce qu'il concerne je
parle en son nom est resté tout à fait
solide sur son terrain mais je dois dire
que le parti socialiste en dépit de la
déception qu'il a éprouvée devant
l'échec de la gauche entend que gauche a
pu constater cependant qu'il était la
seule formation politique à avoir
gains au cours de ces dernières
élections 4% ce n'était pas suffisant
mais après tous les autres partis ont
perdu ses 4 % et si nous avons été en
effet éprouvé par le fait que nous
n'avons pas été mis en mesure d'apporter
aux travailleurs la politique dont il
avait besoin
ressentir désiré par la majorité des
français
si les socialistes n'ont pu obtenir ce
résultat et n'en reste pas moins engagé
dans une dynamique qui doit les conduire
vers des combats politiques futurs qui
sont après tout pas si lointain alors
pourquoi séparer les états majors
jusqu'ici j'ai le sentiment que le parti
socialiste se rencontrent un vaste
courant populaire se mettaient en lors
de sa dernière conférence de presse de
14 balles et risque un destin a proposé
à cinq ans d'initiative qui réponde à
certaines de vos préoccupations
est-ce qu'on s'achemine vers un
consensus vers une cohabitation possible
pouvoir opposition cela aurait pu être
mieux engagée tient quand même cinq
initiatives nouvelles qui vous en grève
quand j'ai rencontré le président de la
république peu de temps après les
élections
j'ai nommé ray je ne reviendrai pas
là-dessus certain nombre de propositions
qui veut paraissait devoir n'ont pas
fourni un statut de l'opposition ce qui
est une notion très choquant mais
établir de meilleures relations de
travail dans la vie démocratique du pays
entre l'opposition et la majorité
monsieur giscard d'estaing a pris une
initiative que nous avons approuvé
quant à la présence d'une demande de
l'opposition notamment socialiste dans
les délégations internationales
j'avais également demandé que l'on put
mettre en oeuvre un projet de
rétablissement de la proportionnelle sur
ce long du procès dure à étudier ni
j'aperçois que sur le plan municipal
monsieur giscard d'estaing semblent
aller dans ce sens demain aux prochaines
élections d'hier dans cinq ans dire
demain un peu imprudent
il y aura des élections municipales pour
les communes de plus de 30000 habitants
à la proportionnelle et non plus sur la
base des listes bloquées que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui très bien on
parle aussi m'a-t-on dit d'un projet de
financement des partis politiques pour
éviter la débauche d'argent qui fait que
les parties riche soutenu par le
yar du patronat ont pu vous écraser par
leur propagande
compte non tenu bien entendu de la
disposition qu'ils ont de la plus grande
presse en france ça c'est ça va dans le
bon sens est ce que ça peu décrisper
suffisamment je pense que le président a
public a été trop timide et n'a pas une
autorité suffisante sur les partis de la
majorité
la preuve en est c'est que à l'intérieur
de l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
l'opposition n'est nulle part
représentée dans les organismes sérieux
que sur les commissions les commissions
de travail d'étude et d'examen
il y a là une crispation dont la
majorité restent eux responsable puisque
nous parlons d'un consensus possible
évoquons un problème qui ne consent
germe jour je perds vite corrigé ce
lundi rue de javel consensus
consentement tout le monde ont
simplement à ce que la démocratie soit
réelle nous ne demandons pas du tout à
jouer le rôle de la majorité nous sommes
l'opposition vous voulez une
cohabitation entre le pouvoir une église
nous voulons que nos droits soient
reconnus ou non tu soit reconnu à la
télévision à la radio
nous voulons qu'il soit reconnu à
l'assemblée nationale nous voulons
qu'ils soient reconnus dans la vie
quotidienne
nous voulons pouvoir dire notre mot
puisque nous sommes nous aussi la france
prenne un réquisitoire visage de
rencontrer les leaders est à la fois de
l'opposition de la majorité avant les
sommets de juillet sur l'économie
mondiale
eh bien vous vous rendrez à cette
invitation si je suis personnellement
invité lui rendrait certainement limité
rampe dans la mesure du mandat du parti
socialiste mais c'est une attitude que
nous avons adoptée sur lequel nous ne
reviendrons pas le problème de la peine
de mort est-ce que vous voterait la
proposition de loi que bernard stasi est
l'un de vos amis à la chana vont essayer
de déposer à l'assemblée la session
puisque seule une question personnelle
oui où
ils sont en ligne avec le député de la
nièvre longtemps que moi en tant que
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
je pourrais vous rappeler que j'ai je
suis signataire du programme de mon
parti et du programme commun de la
gauche qui prévoit une façon peut-être
un peu intemporel le l'abolition la
peine de mort ce rappel est nécessaire
à titre personnel en conscience et c'est
bien un problème de conscience
oui je la voterai pour quoi tu te fous
et à titres intemporels
vous pensez qu'elle est peut être la
circonstance je veux dire que le
programme commun et le programme du
parti socialiste ont été adoptés en 1972
l'un en juin et l'autre en mars et
n'avait pas fixé d'échéance précise au
vote de cette disposition
le gars de l'est soit fait monsieur
perfide a dans le passé plusieurs fois
affirmé qu'il était aussi la peine de
mort et voilà qu'au moment où il en est
responsable
il semble changer d'avis les choses
méritent d'être traités avec précision
c'est une grande responsabilité que de
vous répondre de cette façon car il faut
que ailier barrage contre le crime
contre le terrorisme il faut le plus
souvent que justice soit rendue
de telle sorte que nul ne puisse penser
que la loi s'effritera devant la volonté
barbare des organisations criminelles
mais cependant le problème de la peine
de mort peut-il répondre à cette
question je ne le pense pas sa mi temps
vous avez évoqué le programme commun
vous avez dit un jour qu'il était
forclos l'union la bouche était chez les
filles soient forclos mais si lui
reprendre là dessus c'est une évidence
du canton 6 1 contre 1 quand on signe un
contrat pour cinq ans en 1972
culturellement il se termine a mis le
sens lorient 17 entre vittel et tiennent
du mal à la gorge il est con première
question d'être un peu prolongé puisque
les élections étaient en mars aux 118 en
tant que contrat juridique en tant que
contrat politique
le programme comme je comprends beaucoup
de dispositions dont le parti est
socialiste et est encore aujourd'hui
porteur et pour longtemps puisqu'il ne
pas appliquer ce programme commun mais
cependant sur le plan des structures des
réformes de structure les réformes de
fond et de bon ou de demande purement
conjoncturel se pensent ou smic par
exemple je pense à des réformes
d'éducation là
une halte ce programme commun nous
paraît encore tout à fait actuel mais
sur la base d'un contrat entre partis
communistes radicaux de gauche et parti
socialiste programme de gouvernement ne
sont pas non plus au gouvernement
oui il est fort plus haut puisque il
était pour 50 et nous en sommes à 1978
commune aujourd'hui encore son passé dur
avec vous en vous excusant dans ce
rapport de tout repos prennent que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure des sites
développés les tendances au sein du pc
taylor je crois que je me mêle pas du
tout moi des affaires intérieures du
parti communiste pas du tout ça si
claude peu près un besoin d'être rassuré
je tiens à le lui dire devant l'ensemble
des français qui nous écoutent ce soir
ce ne serait ce pas du tout ce que je
veux dire c'est que le parti communiste
a une certaine propension à attaquer
constamment le parti socialiste
je pense que c'est une responsabilité
dangereuse
déjà le parti communiste l'a fait au
cours des derniers mois qui ont précédé
les élections législatives et il a
précipité l'échec de la gauche il a pris
la responsabilité de l'échec de la
gauche pour s'affirmer en tant que parti
communiste il a préféré que les
travailleurs que l'ensemble des
producteurs que l'ensemble des couches
sociales françaises qui attendait la
victoire de la gauche en soit écarté et
il a mauvaise conscience
alors il ya moins de mauvaise conscience
il entretient une petite guerre à
laquelle je ne veux pas partir je suis
différent le parti socialiste lui même
commence à porte et il en a parlé d'un
complot contre françois mitterrand neveu
ça c est quand je dis on c'est un
certain nombre de journaux lycéens ont
un c'est pas facile à reconnaître
quel complot vu qu'en pas qu'il y ait de
complot contre moi il y à la vérité de
la vie et la force des choses simples
viennent beaucoup aimé mais heureusement
que somme et heureusement que ça
bouillonne beaucoup le parti socialiste
un bouillonnement de vie ou de crise
je crois que c'est un gros événement de
deux filles toute crise provoque de la
fièvre et vous savez un un parti comme
le nôtre qui était un tout petit parti
il y a simplement six ou sept ans qui
est devenu le premier parti en 1978 qui
n'a connu que des succès jusqu'aux
relatif échec de 1978 futur helmand il
faut aborder la nouvelle période
en réfléchissant
en discutant en proposant en cherchant à
mieux comprendre encore ce que veulent
et ce que sont les français et en
s'adressant aux couches sociales aux
français qui n'ont pas voté pour lui
pour faire comprendre que le parti
socialiste c'est le parti le seul
capable dans le cadre de l'union des
forces populaires sur le terrain même où
nous sommes et le seul capable d'assurer
la victoire que nous avons manqué au
mois de mars dernier
alors bien entendu comme c'est un
formidable mouvement qui a rassemblé les
socialistes venus de toute part de
toutes les écoles de pensée de tous les
mouvements de l'histoire qui ont occupé
la france pendant un chèque ennemis
support commode
il paie la dynamique de la dynamique est
là vous dites un peu hétéroclite on a le
sentiment que ça tire un peu à lui à dia
en ce moment au sein du ps vous
connaissez un mouvement de lesquels il
n'y a pas compétition dit les dom là où
il n'y en a pas c'est dangereux
dans ce cas là c'est le pouvoir absolu
d'un seul homme
ou bien c'est l'absence de pensée je
crois pouvoir dire que premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
je crois pouvoir dire que j'ai la
confiance de l'immense majorité des
socialistes pour ne pas dire d'à peu
près tous vous aviez alors récemment je
n'exige pas ils ont le droit de le
contester
d'ailleurs si on ne contestait pas je
finirai par m'ennuyer
ou bien par manquera c'est une bien par
mu sclérosé j'ai besoin du coup de fouet
permanent que représente la discussion
au cd partitions il voyait temps réel
rock à remplir mon roi des dauphins
désumer mais pas ses dauphins sans aucun
doute les successeurs possibles
certainement parmi d'autres et pierre
mauroy et depuis déjà sept ans celui qui
remplit les tâches majeures dans le
parti socialiste avec moi et tout
naturellement s'il m'arrivait quoi que
ce soit qui m'empêchera de poursuivre ma
tâche
il serait là pour tenir bon et il
tiendrait bon c'est un homme solide et
de qualité
c'est pierre mauroy qui à cette charge
si vous me parler de l'avenir de
socialistes dans la vie nationale c'est
l'élection présidentielle toute autre
circonstance
pierre mauroy michel rocard je m'en
réjouis
le parti socialiste compte avec eux et
quelques autres des hommes capables
mené tous les combats après mois moi je
suis là pour essayer de restituer le
socialisme à la france et la france aux
socialistes m'ont longtemps encore eh
bien je me sens je me sens en état
suffisant je dirais même en en bon état
avec l'envié de combattre l'envi de dire
l'envi de restituer la dynamique un
moment altérée par l'échec de mars 1978
j'ai envie de parler aux français j'ai
envie d'entraîner un puissant mouvement
qui transformera les données de notre
société
ce qu une perche intéressante n'est ce
pas air france mise en jeu merci d'avoir
été notre invité pendant 20 minutes
la météo pour terminer c'est la toute
dernière page de ce journal car nous
sommes un petit peu en retard il a fait
beau comme vous l'avez vu aujourd'hui
sur l'ensemble du pays avec des
températures comprises entre 18 et 25
degrés demain premier jour de l'été et
oui de la bretagne et de la vendée à la
frontière belge quelques nuages avec
même des pluies passagères surtout en
fin de journée ailleurs un temps
ensoleillé avec l'après midi quelques
orages isolés en fin de soirée vers
23h30 vous retrouverez pierre-alain
après le dossier l'écran pour le dernier
journal quant à moi je vous retrouverai
demain et je vous quitte à vous remercie
de votre attention
excellente soirée à tous au revoir
à